Jenna do you know what we're doing today
what we are going to be exploring a
bunch of really incredible earpods cases
have you heard of this kind of
phenomenon that's happening or has
already happened and I linked a trend I
actually have not but you've been
talking about it for at least three
weeks now so I guess I have heard about
it
she's heard about it and now we're gonna
show you guys some earpods cases when
you thinking about earpods cases what do
you think about Jenna I mean like a
normal case for your airpot look simple
like little small put your earbuds in
protects it this is the opposite
complete opposite of that I have about
like 35 36 of these that I ordered off
Amazon I'm not even sure if they all
ended up coming in but that's a steak
avocado nota Starbucks how we getting
away with this I'm not sure these all I
think in from China there's some kind of
crazy knockoff but either way let's
unbag these and test them out of our air
buds
I've so many questions you know you can
just go alright I want to judge
[Music]
Grayson will each take a turn which one
is your I guess favorite or least
favorite least favorite how many am I
allowed to pick well my favorite I think
so far I really enjoyed this an Xbox
controller oh there's another Xbox
controller for the older this was a new
air box
okay so you put yours in there I'll put
mine in here I stick it in there like
this
and then I just do like that yeah looks
like it has a little here this is heavy
it's pretty heavy
I feel like this would actually I feel
like I would lose my air pods
this thing I feel like if anything this
would like just a lie open and then my
air pop that's that sneaks that's mostly
plastic and chemicals this sandwich oh
you know like when they give you like a
like a spinach feta wrap next look how
freaking cute this is it's a little dog
look at this little tiny dog oh my god
you would never suspect those are air
pops
absolutely not always have fell off okay
doesn't quite work that well this is
probably my favorite like this is super
cute have you not seen toad I have seen
toad I ordered all of these look at them
tada little mushroom head oh my goodness
I'm just not sure how they're getting
around copyright look at this one this
one stinks this literally says
Nintendo's which I know I like this one
don't know if like these are really that
practical
[Music]
because it's not early bald babe like
the one that we have from nomads is
really nice it's like a nice leather
case it's super slick these also were
very inexpensive I was just gonna say
how much do they cost like like all our
sounded like three dollars yeah this was
nice it's a very low profile definitely
doesn't fit very well I can't believe
how bad these smell feel so but I'm
actually getting a headache from like
the chemicals in the plastic it's
hurting my throat action yeah as a weird
thing so this one that I'm gonna open
now this was the most expensive one
it is a knockoff just ship it on sale
and the quality is very self par okay
actually this is quite nice I was
actually really nice how much did this
cost
maybe $38 oh no sorry I raised my voice
because I was disgusted by the price
Kevin this actually is perfect because
it has this nice little clip on it and
it stays in there oh actually it doesn't
stay into that gray because as soon as
you open this the whole thing pulls out
hate when that happens
oh my god this is really this is a lot
of trash look at this one there's a
cheeseburger okay yeah mmm
sesame seeds is this haha that is Yoda
oh my gosh yeah watch Mandalorian happen
I have it now I've been watching
everything else on every other network
though I love the Mandalorian the show
wasn't hard of hold the finale
was there was a very upsetting part for
me but I'm still traumatized wrong yeah
cute boy where do we go from here is the
problem
Oh an avocado you say this is a smiling
avocado alright this one's okay we've
been like talking a lot about like
you're the hiring quality of these
things okay well that's not really that
what is so I'm not sure because and does
that go with something does it go with
this one in the world what I want I
squeak toy now he's gonna go change
first let's see if Maddie comes up okay
I hate it so we're gonna put this little
unicorn on this is really cool really
really cool here no you put that on is
that crap you're gonna lose if they
didn't see my air pot weird layer box
are they my air box this is so this is
this is stupid it's stupid but it
actually it's kinda cute so I'm kind of
conflicted like I don't know if I hate
it or love it
why can't get a bell I don't know
okay next you're interested it's me the
neat if I ever saw someone in real life
get their air pods out of a stake ear
pods case I would call the police
no picture of this I said Jim ready to
go on a little jog I'm like oh I can
even get my earplugs out 911 to come in
a crime this woman's case sidious is
that is that what's that egg character
he has a name
you have a hat yes right here oh there
it is
Oh what is that called oh shoot
ah his bottle I have peeled him oh he's
he's a layer boy it's interesting but
look that's just more layers to lose uh
oh I just mean has fallen
what is this a character called leave me
a comment below I know you guys know
none of these even lined up right like
they're just weird and I don't know how
we transition from that to this crystal
goodness have you seen anything more
beautiful oh my god I'm never gonna get
this off there no you're not oh wait
this also went with a little egg Wow and
there's even a little cutout for the the
light is this cookie I'm so furious I
can't get this freakin thing out of here
oh my gosh they're in my mouth you look
so cute that's cute
that's super cute don't touch it to your
mouth it'll smell so bad okay next up
what was this this beautiful rose gold
masterpiece a gem beautiful rose gold
masterpiece it also has this amazing
little it definitely looks better on
camera than real life you think looks so
shiny what do you have over there
oh my goodness either it's pretty cool
really cute definitely wouldn't be
something that I would actively choose
to have as my case though no show this
one what is dirty inside but I guess
it's fitting because it's a pig so I'm
gonna put my palms in there oh no my
paws are dirty he's spitting for my
shitty cute Jenna walked in my house
today was like your disgust I go this is
gross I have the pleasure bodies we've
got a few more left I'm saving the best
for last and it's not this well actually
that might be pretty good this is pretty
good one so when I saw that first from
the side I thought it was Heinz ketchup
so when it said vanilla I was confused
oh no put up put our ice cream top on
really bad it's cute have you ever had
the the peanut butter chocolate peanut
butter half and all but
sounds so good gosh I can't believe like
who really rolls around town with
somebody's on some of them are cool some
are just a real a crime where I'm they
really are a crime okay I have the best
for last I have saved it does that add
up that it does it is the poop emoji
case I mean this is beautiful it opens
nicely it's smiling at me absolutely not
a little profile this could not be any
more obnoxious little foot brain you can
wear that as jewelry you're sad but this
is nice huh I can't believe it is this I
don't know I don't know how I feel I
think it's a really cute accessory you
know if you want to try to be an
individual be unique this is my favorite
the total one's pretty nice house is the
best some of them don't really stay on
very well like this just pops right off
so easily
well can you put this in your bag you're
gonna lose it well that's it I guess
I'll put some links in the description
if you guys are interested in any of
these I don't think I recommend buying
them I mean if you maybe buy one
don't buy more than that at all don't do
it no save your money
I try to tell her to save her money and
I was offended when she told me how many
she bought I have anxiety now what are
you gonna do with all of these I don't
know well guys thanks for watching
Happy New Year if I haven't told you
already what am I gonna do with these I
can't return them
[Music]